[Musique]
pour se déplacer de château en château
tous été transportés avec des coffres
avec une poignée de chaque côté le
coffre au départ c'était tout simple
avec deux poignées terminé est là après
on améliore et on a le sens du beau
[Musique]
d'avoir des coffres au ras du sol ce
n'est pas très commode
du coup on a fait des coffres au en fait
et on enlevait les poignées puisqu'on
n'a plus besoin de les bouger
on comprend le coffre et on le met sur
un bâti sur des pieds des jambes comme
ça il est à hauteur et la grande
invention c'est que le kof lui en
ouvrait le dessus du coffre et
maintenant il reste fermé mais
maintenant il a une porte et comme ça
c'est beaucoup plus facile d'accès
ça c'est le mot qui tue parce que croire
crédence croire ça servait pour mettre
des objets précieux comme ici par
exemple des objets du culte
vous voyez où un calice des choses comme
ça donc ça pouvait servir de coffre-fort
si on veut ici dans la chambre du roi ça
servait aussi pour enfermer les mais
pour qu on empoisonne pas ça arrivait
les cuisines on le mettait là et après
on peut elle servir à la personne aux
rois ou seigneur qui étaient là et on
était sûr que personne ne puisse y
toucher pour avoir le pouvoir on était
prêt à tout soit ont trahi ssait soit en
empoisonnait ou soit on assassinait et
les choses n'ont pas beaucoup changé
d'ailleurs parce que le pouvoir rend fou
[Musique]